so first of all I just want to say you
all did an amazing job on this film
honestly when I sat there watching it
always brought back to being six years
old watching it through my dad's
fingertips and that's honestly how I
felt all over again so great job thank
you thank you so cool that was great
yeah so everyone in this movie you were
all pretty much a badass for idiom when
we have the Terminator we have grace
super soldier mm-hmm and we have Danny
obviously um because you're all such big
characters I want to know was there
anything that surprised you while you
were getting ready for this character
the sense that I think what was
surprising was its plenty in a film like
this of this size you know spanning over
seven months stuff that you've prepared
for at the beginning is not being shot
until the end all this and then you know
you take two weeks to shoot two minutes
it's all of that I knew that that was
the case but to actually experience it
and to try to keep a through line and
trying to keep your momentum and stay
part of the shoot as you know sometimes
you have days off and how do you stay
active you you go and you make them you
force them to schedule some stunt
rehearsals and you do your training you
do all that so what was surprising is
just how it actually felt to be in this
thing that's been a time just being
extended and and really the the
meticulous nature of it so that to me
that was an experience new experience
yeah yeah I think the Tim our director
is such an exhaustive planner and
prepare and he included us and so much
of the like pre-visualization these sort
of digital animations of what the stunts
were gonna be so you'd see before we
were gonna do a week before a month
before six months before you all you
knew what was coming up all the time but
I you're sort of like
this is the day I'm hanging from the
Hummer and the waterfall this is when
I'm like falling through the night sky
on the Hummer and I'm like slashing the
thing and then when you actually do it
you're like what is happening because
it's just so much bigger and and more
insane than you could have possibly
imagined even though you saw it yeah I
mean for me it was everything was a
surprise like I think every day I was
like amazed by something like ah but I
was just like pretending it was normal
for me but yeah it's just the whole size
of this movie you know just like the
amount of trailers and people and and
food and you know like everything was
just like overwhelming for me you know
but but that's why I loved it you know
it was just like learning and trying to
understand this new world and language
so it was you know amazing and you kind
of touched on it just now Mackenzie but
through the process of becoming your
characters was there a moment where
either on sets or maybe during training
to body in shapes or your mental
training was that moment that you're
kind of like wow I am a badass I feel
like there were constant fluctuating
moments of that and then I mean it's
just the move like you constantly feel
like yeah I'm really doing this and then
an immediate drop and sense of failure
so it was just sort of managing those
two things at all times I mean you would
terminate come on yeah well there was
there was a day where we were doing um
Arnold and I are fighting it at the back
of the plane and then he was sitting in
his chair having a you know well he
wasn't smoking and Dorothy was just kind
of had the cigar you know in his teeth
and he was just watching me do my side
of it and because we're just doing this
this kind of special shot of looking up
and I'm about to just stab him and and
he I came off and I wasn't set my chair
next to him he's like you know you move
your body very well and I just took that
as to be I mean I didn't I I guess I
felt a little bit bad ass in that moment
just because I was getting a compliment
from when the greatest accident stars of
in all history and so yeah maybe
in that moment I let myself have a like
that you you all did such an awesome job
and I I really mean it I think you
should all feel like badasses you really
were in that film I can't believe you
weren't just like yeah I know obviously
it was a lot harder than what I saw
I'll be back
you